[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and this is one of those rare but
wonderful days where news has broken
right before we go live so because this
is a totally live show broadcasting from
the new Rockstar's headquarters we're
able to react to it in real time uh the
news of a Deadpool of three release date
just came out we're gonna be playing the
video that announced the news we're
going to be reacting to it we're going
to be given some theories it's gonna be
a lot of fun with me to do that to have
that fun I've got Brandon
yeah oh my god I've got Whitney
and Tommy keep it Gucci yes as always
and I'm Zach uh and again this is the
nerdy news show that that talks about
all the stuff that we want to be talking
about including Deadpool 3 today
um but also on today's show we're going
to be talking black panther wakanda
forever a scrapped post-credit scene
from the first movie could be impacting
this movie uh werewolf by night ratings
um we got some Andor episode four uh
fantasy picks courtesy of Mr bechtold Uh
Kevin feige teasing Scarlet Witch's
return and some other fun stuff uh but
first oh oh also for every hundred
dollars in the super chat today we
appreciate Christian unpronounceable
Austin long already a couple folks
throwing us some new balloons there in
the chat we appreciate you uh for every
100 one host will be punching into one
of these mystery boxes that are
precariously placed here at the front
and we'll see a mystery will unfold I
didn't know this was like a Fight Club
thing yeah
you just kind of want to go I want you
to kill anything inside one of them oh
[ __ ] Are there live animals there could
be we don't know whatever they sell
destroyer's buckets buckets baby let's
go the lady at Party City when I checked
out said no
okay uh so a mystery will unfold
um but uh today we've got to talk about
just less than an hour ago Ryan Reynolds
released a video on Instagram
um announcing uh Deadpool 3 making it
official giving it a release date in
theaters and uh mentioning a very
special guest uh now we we're just gonna
play an edited version of that clip here
and then we'll react to it so
producer John can you roll that
beautiful footage
hey everyone uh we're extremely sad to
have missed d23 but we've been working
very hard on the next Deadpool film for
uh a good long while now his first
appearance in the MCU obviously needs to
feel special buying new depth and
motivation new meaning every Deadpool
needs to stand out and stand apart
it's been an incredible challenge that
has forced me to reach down deep inside
and I have nothing
but we did have one idea
hey Hugh you want to play Wolverine one
more time
yeah sure
[Music]
it's 24. I can't wait that long well you
have to uh and we're going to talk about
a bunch of stuff where this fits in the
phase six uh the other properties it has
a very interesting place in between
other uh announced Marvel properties
what this could mean how they're gonna
fit Deadpool and Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine into the MCU there's a lot to
talk about and we will get to it we will
get to it but for now we've got to talk
about our other headlines headlines of
the day
what's up
um real quick I want to come back to the
Andor headline because that I think is
also really interesting okay Brandon I
know you prepared okay
so I'm just hold on to it my man pinch
it off
um uh some other headlines Uh Kevin
feige is out there teasing with Olson's
MCU returned did I get your tummy uh
yeah he had this to say uh he was asked
about Elizabeth Olsen and he said if I
could work with Lizzy for another 100 I
would work with her for another 100
years if we could and of course the only
limitation there being human lifespans
spiders Kevin and Lizzy in 100 years the
planet's gonna be 9 000 degrees on its
surface so unless they're all playing
ice people
I just need the fans at home to know
that Brandon hates Lizzie
he loves Elizabeth and he does not like
it that I don't like adults how do you
feel about Bob De Niro Bobby Bobby D
that's fine
specifically Lizzy when her boss is like
oh Lizzy's coming over her name is Dame
Elizabeth Olsen no she must be
introducing herself as like call me yeah
which is fine but we don't know that as
the public it seems like they're nagging
her and I don't like it I introduced
myself as Lizzy and nobody literally
nobody even you're crazy
but he went on to say when asked like oh
well will you see her in the MCU again
he said anything's possible in the
Multiverse we'll have to see what a
[ __ ] ass answer yeah it really is that
is truly Mikey come on the break room
and sit on my lap yeah tell us what you
really feel can you call her Lizzy
who calls her Lizzy simu calls her
Elizabeth yeah yeah and then he goes
it's an honor to work with you Elizabeth
as two of the royal royal people in this
franchise is encounter to work with
siemer's Canadian they're all very
polite they use formal names I'm sorry
Lizzy in other MCU news uh Ryan coogler
director of the first black panther film
and the upcoming black panther wakanda
forever uh told Empire magazine that
there was a scrapped black panther
post-credits scene from the first film
uh he said in the first film there there
was plans for a stinger where the camera
would push through the palace in wakanda
and then we'd see wet Footprints leading
up to the throne oh you gotta love a
good wet foot yes I do though I went off
on this earlier how long was it from
when Neymar was in water until he got to
the throne room to have these like wet
Footprints it's not right next to the
water because you're you're your suit
still keeps dripping water he's in a
suit he walks on Barefoot he lives
underwater but the time it takes for him
to get to the water to the throne he can
fly Brandon he is constantly moist
is there a chance
that t'challa took a shower didn't dry
his feet enough and walked to the throne
someone called it out he got really
embarrassed and he was like that's got
to be Neymar that's gotta be nice I mean
sometimes in my room when I'm in a real
hurry because I've overslept for our
morning meeting there's wet Footprints
leading all the way to my computer
there's also Reese's Pieces rappers
Seasons get slippers I think slippers
are for kids they're not they're
beautiful I think the main takeaway here
is they don't make them for myself when
there were two sets of web Footprints we
were walking side by side yeah when
there was only one set of wet footprints
uh Whitney we Whitney we're having a uh
a technical issue you can go see our
friends
um speaking of what if he kills the
Black Panther franchise uh we got some
uh rumors of the runtime have come out
again that film's coming out in just a
little bit over two months uh that the
film is gonna be two hours 41 minutes if
you like you soon uh Black Panther I get
ready for a big old bowl of it baby
early don't drink anything during the
film do not it's a sucker's bet to drink
anything during the film no drink after
to forget about it no find more about
that on Tommy's time tidbits dot org uh
I'm only 20 years old so my prostate is
great born in 2008. my bladder is
awesome but like when they introduce
beer into movies I still can't drink it
but I hear that like having bare at
movies is great but then you're drinking
beers and now you had a pizza oh yeah it
is actually the worst I will say this
we'll be doing a lot of kind of forever
content when that film comes out
including thing we will give you time
stamps for when during the movie is a
good moment that's a scene that you can
miss you can run to the bathroom during
that two minute window or whatever
um but just as a frame of reference film
supposedly is two hours and 41 minutes
this is like from some news coming from
theaters who have been warned of like
run time so they know how to stagger
their screenings uh Spider-Man no way
home was two hours 28 minutes
you can make it if you're not getting
the Big Gulp or whatever end game was
three hours two minutes so it's still a
good 20 minutes shorter than anything
Turtles I was surprised to see this
Brandon Brandon brought this up eternals
which I didn't think of as a long movie
but two hours 36 minutes basically the
same length it was I forgot that because
I thought eternals was just the length
of the movie all right on eternity I saw
Turtles with John when I very first got
hired and I was too nervous to drink in
front of my new co-worker so I did it I
have time
so like I remember the whole movie
theater I just remembered the whole time
they were on the like volcano I was like
this oh come on finish the movie wait
wait wait wait wait was that you trying
to finish yeah
to you much
I'm trying amazing he's about to Tia nut
if you know oh I know
um speaking of phase six properties so
still no casting about Fantastic Four
producer John claims to have some Scoops
he refuses to share with us but um one
scoop that that has kind of come out is
so uh marvelous Miss maisel actress
Rachel Brosnahan has addressed the
rumors that she's been cast as Sue storm
in Fantastic Four that her quote was I
haven't heard anything unfortunately but
I'm here it's our last season I'm about
to be available classic thirsty thespian
language right there please ask me there
it is there's that graphic Google
he also need to update the characters
that one actress is like as a very small
role in a niche property
um we got to get Rachel bresnahan in
there um but yeah she was asked if she
would sign on to a Fantastic Four
project she said absolutely that would
be a blast no [ __ ] Rachel yeah hey John
by the way open up the Baskin Rob
obviously start scooping okay we're sick
of you hoarding all the job John claims
to have all these in Hollywood insiders
feeding him stuff all the time that he
refuses to share with I'm gonna have a
cow I'm cow
no secrets of mine I'll take them to my
grave
uh less than two weeks away we're
getting werewolf By Night on Disney plus
Marvel special presentation
um and director Michael giacchino said
that um it was almost rated TV MA which
is the heaviest have television we're
gonna see some dicks yeah I want to see
some werewolves music
Curry boners is that is that the that's
the Boomer uh
bingo board
um it is not rated tvma it's rated TV 14
but apparently it was right there on the
precipice so yeah we would hope it's
gonna have some violence some horror
themed scary not for the little kids so
I think that's a good sign yeah and I
think they can go like I'm gonna have
sex with you but they can't show it they
can declare it well and he said they
were when they were shooting it they're
like oh this is gonna be TVM hey this is
intense but he also said because it's in
black and white they think they got away
with the violence
it's not just like realistic I guess
yeah that's how I know they're going to
show dicks Black and Whites obviously if
they if they passed the gore ratings the
only thing left is Dicks because I think
man thing smokes
so I uh the networks wouldn't touch Mad
Men look it up
um okay also speaking of werewolf by
night uh Michael GI Aquino he addressed
some Cameo possibilities said they
considered characters like blade But
ultimately it exists in the same world
as all of these other things it does but
let's not worry worry about that right
now something that you could just drop
in on not having seen anything else and
just enjoy it for what it was which I
like that right like they don't have to
worry about Canon and like connections
to other properties it's going to be a
nice self-contained fun thing do you
think that's a cya like a cover your ass
like uh there is a cameo and he doesn't
want to spoil it oh
right because because he didn't name
drop blade and we I mean we've already
had a blade Cameo so it's like what's
the value of however like nine blade
cameos yeah
um but who knows that could be fun I
mean there will be some interesting
characters for sure okay now I want to
come back to okay
so the most recent episode of Andor
episode three watch it folks if you're
not watching Andrew what's wrong that
show is so good okay it doesn't have a
lot of heat yet not a lot of folks are
watching it or watching our content
about it Ketchup they hook up on on
Andor people have sex people in Star
Wars having sex
they're not even on tattooing yeah
from there
foreign
[Applause]
ER
cheese
we can do this all day
um but so in that most recent episode uh
we keep getting all these great
flashbacks to Young Casa before he was
even called Cassian yeah and this is
gonna be a very mild spoiler if you
haven't seen episode three it's actually
not that big a deal and it's on tonight
episode four so catch up yeah uh this
isn't that this won't really spoil
anything for the show but we see this
young gassian Casa uh we see this downed
ship and we see these uh figures most of
whom have already died yeah they're
yellow they're like maybe poison some
sort of biological disaster I don't know
one of them as a mask I thought they
were Simpsons
oh they're just sick no uh and they are
all wearing the same uniform with a very
specific patch on it Brandon could you
go into a little bit we see in the show
like these these Dead figures they have
like the separatist patch which was the
patch of remember the Clone Wars the
droid army and Goku they were
separatists some people involved with
that were just like anti-republic they
weren't necessarily evil they got they
were just on that side and then the
Republic the Clone Troopers that was the
Republic all that kind of stuff right so
some of these Dead figures they have the
like separatist patch now
of Star Wars Disney whoever officially
on their website is putting out these
like episode guides with like little
Easter eggs and like episode summaries
and they show one where it's like a
picture and they're saying like this is
during the flashback uh when uh when
they're kind of exploring the ship Marva
Marva and Clem yeah uh and they
eventually images this is prior to this
to uh the Clone Wars starting which is
already kind of weird uh and then Chief
is Marvis says like that these kids
there's a republic chick coming and she
says these kids killed a republic
officer now they're wearing separages
Insignia so they're not and in theory
the separatists are fighting the
Republic they are not the right problems
this is the opposite side of that war so
there's several things at play here that
is very confusing from this first of all
uh supposedly Cassian was born in 26 BBY
26 before 26 baby 26 baby so in theory
he's 26 when he dies in zero BBY
here we go
so and then them saying that like this
happened prior to the Clone Wars which
the Clone Wars are officially like 22
BBY to 19 BBY so this is like 23 24
maybe why I don't know right they're on
this ship so in theory Cassian is only
like three years old but he's clearly
older than that now we know from this
episode too uh she fakes his history so
maybe they gave him a fake birthday so
we can't trust his birthday anymore
that's fine but the fact that she says
that they killed some Republic officers
when they're not wearing Republic
insignias there's a couple things that
is weird here one is this ship a
republic ship and she just assumes the
officers were Republic officers and it
was taken over by separatists in a crash
that could possibly be it two does she
know that these are Republic officers
wearing separatist uniforms in some sort
of false Flagship Eric pointed that out
in the breakdown Star Wars has a long
history of like Rebels wearing
Stormtrooper outfits and stuff like that
like at this point there's not really
even Rebels right there's a Republic and
the separatists and the Clone Wars would
have you believe that republics are good
people but they're not both sides are
bad okay this is this war is bad for
everyone the Jedis have sided do you
think there's a potential third thing
here right Marva and Clem are just too
like you know Loose Cannon there's
scavengers what out there for their own
they don't care if you're a separatist
or republican yeah they don't they don't
care about either side of it they're all
just republics and that's like the third
option they don't know what they're
talking about and they see a republic
ship and they just assume these are
Republic officers so yeah I don't know a
little confusing uh Eric goes into it
more on his breakdown also and I think
you know and it's a little confusing and
like the episodes can drop tonight maybe
it'll clarify some of this stuff maybe
it will they'll identify one of these
options this all could get resolved
later but yeah we saw this official
guide thing and we were like wait what
this is confusing it's just another
thing like The Duffer Brothers
forgetting that Will's birthday yeah was
like I mean that could be possible like
Tony Gilroy I mean he was used using
people from lucasfilm to help him like
kind of fill in some of the holes on
this but who knows if everyone was
talking I personally think that you know
Disney was like we gotta promote Android
more let's put out some episode guides
they made some intern do it and like
some intern got it wrong and to be clear
about all this stuff this is that does
not affect the show this is the kind of
minutia we at new rockstars love we go
back and forth on slack about this all
day long Eric goes into detail and his
breakdowns Tommy and Eric talked about
on Wikileaks but like yeah you do not
need to understand any of the bbys none
of this will impact your enjoyment of
that show which you need to be watching
that show is it's really good yeah what
is up with like the low numbers of
people watching this show I don't get it
well I think when they drop three
episodes at once it intimidated people
are like I don't got three hours to sit
around and it took me a couple days to
get through it all like we have so much
to do here and there's right now with
Rick and Morty Lord of the Rings
House of the Dragon there's a lot of
stuff going on they didn't necessarily
promote this a ton but word of mouth is
going to be big for the show we think
people are going to discover it in time
um real quick while we're talking Star
Wars stuff Star Wars owned by Disney as
is Pixar and Marvel yeah
I like to play games on my phone while I
watch TV I'm not the only one who does
that right I don't own a phone or a TV
so no while you're watching TV you
monsters Tommy lives in the woods I have
a man come over and do shadow puppets
with three hours a night that's how you
consume Andor that's how I watch and wow
he's gorgeous
um Sans anyway uh folks out there if
you're like me and your your brain is so
mush uh by technology that you need to
be consuming two different forms of
entertainment at the same time I just
want to recommend Disney Emoji Blitz
they're a sponsor of the show is a
really fun simple Match 3 Style game you
can play on your phone they use like IP
from Pixar Disney Star Wars you can have
you know your Monsters Inc character you
know and Mickey and and Sebastian from
Little Mermaid are all on there it is
insanely fun to play very addictive it's
a nice second screen kind of experience
uh click there should be a link in the
description of this video or you can go
to jamcity dot me slash Emoji rockstars
download it you know if you're looking
for a fun silly game for yourself yes
the clock stopwatch those will not smash
together I want to go on a field trip to
Kansas City with my friends
Emoji rock stars it's a I'm telling you
I've been playing it a little bit yeah
it's a very fun game if you like a
little second screen action go for it
yes uh and then uh are the only people
technically keeping our bodies and our
internal systems functioning we want to
shout out our friends over at athletic
greens oh and they're barely alive
oh yeah well I mean midichlorians I
always think of them as green I know
they probably don't have a color per se
but athletic greens and their products
specifically ag1 which is what we got
here in here
um is this great you know one scoop of
this in the morning take care of
yourself I know book Brandon and Tommy
uh consume this on a regular basis
regular basis every day I'm hanging on
by a thread can I add it to my Mountain
Dew I wouldn't
it'll just be a mountain double do you
know um uh one every scoop of ag1
whether you're consuming it in in water
like me or in uh poisonous uh sugar
water like uh Whitney I'm gonna die so
soon
I've consumed swimming pools of Mountain
Dew in my life I'm uh I know it will do
me uh you know it won't do me ag1 with
its 75 high quality vitamins minerals
and Whole Foods Source superfoods uh one
thing I've been thinking about a lot
I've started doing more EG ones is I've
been sleeping great I've got a growing
family and the newest member of that
family wakes me up a lot in the middle
of the night and uh this helps sleep
restfulness and uh alertness once you're
awake and some of the all the different
minerals and stuff like that help those
symptoms mental Clarity uh so with ag1
you're getting all in one nutritional
insurance it's much cheaper than and
sourcing all of those healthy
ingredients herself it's a nice little
habit with big benefits you know you
don't got to worry about any of uh oh
I'm not getting enough of this vitamin
or that nutrient right that's probably
why I'm not feeling good and my Skin's
bad or whatever right this takes care of
all of that so reclaim your health and
arm your immune system with convenient
daily nutrition one scoop and a cup of
water every day that's it head to
athletic
greens.com break room uh that's how you
get a good deal and they know we sent
you that helps us out helps you out
again that's athletic greens.com break
room take ownership over your health and
pick up the ultimate daily nutritional
Insurance okay that's good real quick I
just want to say on and or this is
pretty important okay
the only way we're going to get people
to start watching Andor is if you shout
it from your word of mouth
to your hell down south okay
map to the hell down south baby let's go
let's go get it out there from your
Marvel mouth to your Bix
we gotta talk about Deadpool okay but
first Whitney has to open yeah I just I
just wanted to say really quick I saw uh
Sir Psycho sidekick that is him uh say
congrats on the engagement yes I know
that that's a Red Hot Chili Peppers
restaurant here restaurant reference
it's not a restaurant I meant to say
references
the blood sugar Sex Magic dessert is
delicious there okay Boomers you have to
eat it with us steak Knife con job card
shark boot cut yeah um I really like
that song and I and I thank you on the
well wishes
Winnie's gonna go through a mystery box
here uh we have no idea what's in there
well Tommy does but uh thanks to Ben
Enoch Mikey cheers uh well-rounded mom
and everybody's sending in super chats
okay
whichever one you want okay
um
[Music]
[Applause]
we're so excited we literally had a
whole other show planned and we had to
throughout the script like it was Avatar
2's first draft if you're a fan of the
show you get that reference yeah so Ryan
Reynolds he announced Deadpool 3's
release date in September 6 2024 tickets
go on sale right now I'm just kidding uh
we don't know what tickets go on sale uh
but even more than that Hugh Jackman is
coming back he's gonna return his
Wolverine we know always leaving Music
Man soon so this is perfect timing for
him uh exciting like big big time stuff
and this seems like I think even the the
logo with the claws going through it the
rip through it makes me think this is
more than just like a cameo yeah yeah
which is a big promise yeah uh Hugh
Jackman is Wolverine has cameo'd in
other films before right he's not beyond
that but it does seem like yeah they
were this is maybe gonna be like a buddy
movie or something I want it to be that
I want to just be like two guys being
dudes having a good time fun stuff their
friends well even if obviously
Wolverine's gonna be very reluctant and
so is Deadpool but in real life they're
friends and I like it when friends do
stuff together and I think it's gonna be
so fun just because of how much they're
getting rich men with businesses that
make them even yeah exactly and this has
been just like the longest running
inside job so like it's it's gonna pay
off and it's pretty good now it would be
great if Wolverine's down this movie at
all yeah
he just watches a cartoon of X-Men 97
he's like wow Wolverine is so much Ryan
Reynolds starts the movie by being like
he died in Logan he's dead that would be
great if it gets replaced by cartoon
Wolverine halfway through the movie oh
yeah he's like you get out of here I
mean it could be it could be interesting
right like no character got a better
kind of like finality than Logan in
Logan right like it's a beautiful movie
yeah and there are some people that are
a little disappointed like oh no you get
to end perfectly but hey uh Patrick
Stewart's already come back maybe this
can be a totally different Logan
different Universe different Multiverse
yeah it doesn't have to be there not as
not as ripped yeah you don't have to get
that ripped here
please let the only HGH be in your name
with a u in between uh and then I I see
a lot of people bringing this up in the
chat uh I think we even got a super chat
about it John Krasinski also just
tweeted out they're like oh is this our
movie oh thirsty now uh I think this is
the Tweet yeah yeah this is like a big
uh this is a McGuffin I think yeah but
what's interesting is this movie is said
to come out September 6 2024. that's
right before November 2024 which is
Fantastic Four right there so yeah is
is John krasinskien Fantastic Four is he
going to show up maybe in Deadpool as
like Mr Fantastic these movies are we
were we've been talking about this so
this is this will be beginning phase six
right phase five will end with
Thunderbolts
um and Captain America new world order
right those are both at the end of 2020
there it is thank you John those are
both at the end of 2023 then boom the
beginning or well I guess that's not
quite the beginning it's kind of like
late that next year we get these two
films right right and this September 6th
what
three months later yeah the September
6th
uh it was this was a date that was
originally in February of 2024 and then
got pushed to September and we we've
talked about this on the break room
before right like there's all these
announced release dates of movies but we
know that like Marvel has told theaters
like also hold this date in this day in
this day for us without like the
specific property attached to it now one
of those was February got moved to the
following September now we know that
that is Deadpool three right and I
wonder if that was always Deadpool's
spot if they were gonna have it out in
February and they've now needed to Pivot
and change is the does this mean that
Ryan's tying more into the MCU uh uh as
Deadpool which I I think is very
interesting I mean in this the thing we
saw the the little clippy put out like
he's wearing an interesting suit it is
not the Deadpool suit we know it's not
even red at all but it is weirdly like
superhero
it has some elements of like some of the
Wolverine suits we've seen him wear
right even the original
uh he who must not be named directed
X-Men guys what if that wasn't even
Wolverine in the commercial what if that
was just a body I mean it's really hard
to see I think it's just a guy I think
that it's like when they've replaced
Melania with the body double I think
that they replaced Hugh Jackman with a
Melania it's a cute whack man you're
whack man
if it was Zach he'd be a Hugh Jackman
this whole thing is a little sucks to me
I better call my bae
what did Wired Magazine okay I guess
they just watched that clip and I think
their review was they said oh they
didn't like it huh uh well we were
really parsing the language of this
release and if you didn't notice uh it
does have a Whitney Houston song at the
end yes uh I will always love you but
the lyric has changed to Iowa always
love Hugh which is is really clever
really good but he also says every
Deadpool is different or something to
that nature yeah now is does that mean
that this is a different Deadpool a
variant
could we have Deadpool could we have
multiple Deadpools in this film uh going
up against each well it's also very
interesting him saying every Deadpool is
different right dimple one 2016 Deadpool
2 2018 like they came out pretty close
to each other and the characters aren't
that different one to the next right
different arcs in those films and
whatever but like it didn't feel like it
didn't feel like the difference between
Thor the Dark World and Thor Ragnarok
right that character is very different
between those these two and and now uh
quick we know some of the um the talent
behind this film so it's going to be
directed by
um Sean
Levy the guy who did free guy with Ryan
Reynolds their uh previous collaborators
it's gonna be written by
um Wendy's the original writers are
working on it but the main script is
written by Wendy Molino and her sister
also something Malino whose name I can't
remember uh who work on Bob's Burgers
and have done a lot of uh look at this
comedy animation writing back into the
MCU pipeline God I should have written
for the Simpsons you know did you turn
that gig down down matt Brandon was
calling him every day not today
macaroni and he's like it's pronounced
grinning and I'm like okay man well it's
great I ain't no sus we have gotten a
few super chats talking about this read
call center of Super Chat saying I think
there will be like a road trip
Multiverse film for Deadpool 3 where at
the end they enter Marvel 616 and see
Miss Marvel and Neymar that would be
interesting if they're like kind of
jumping around I love the idea of like
you know this really breaking the fourth
wall and like this is I I I think I
pitched this before but the idea that
this comes out as like a fox
a studio or a 20th century films movie
and not an MCU it doesn't need to
connect to anything yeah and Ryan
Reynolds or Deadpool is pissed and it's
him breaking into the MCU like no no my
movie is a Marvel movie it's not a 20th
century Studios movie but me and the MCU
yeah uh and he uses Wolverine to get in
I like it and they you know I would be I
would love a scene where like Deadpool
is confronting Kevin feige and it's like
what gets mad oh that would actually be
great I've brought Wolverine with so
much well and actually there was just a
uh something in the chat just saying
like what if this is because it's coming
out right so close to Fantastic Four
like what if there is like an incursion
taking place between these two realities
right like we know that's kind of that's
what John Krasinski mentions in
Multiverse Madness and like it's
obviously a big comic storyline right
like these like incursions cause like
these two realities to decimate each
other
um the realities of the fox library and
the uh Disney Library yeah um but they
just kill problematic directors
like Ratner versus Whedon
uh
I know
I don't know when they had each other
like the Animated Series
cut I yell cut then I say action you
want action rolling okay wow real quick
when I shout out there's a lot of great
super chats thank you everybody throwing
in super chats sort of psycho sidekick
Sam from their X-Wing to their sex swing
I'm into that's a really good one MLS
speed test it's Deadpool with Wolverine
being an alternate world or in the
current MCU 616. I think they have to
end in the current six months yeah they
cannot start there well yeah there is a
slight chance right with Marvel's
willingness with werewolf uh By Night to
do these special presentations right
which we don't know that it will connect
to anything else or like need to like
exist within the broader MCU could this
be like just a way to wrap up the deer
the Deadpool franchise it just on its
own doesn't need to connect anything
else oh yeah
obsessed with being Deadpool too like
and like he's richer than God I can't
imagine that he could he'd probably just
be like how much how many bottles of
whatever his company Aviation gin do I
need to give how many more Welsh soccer
teams must I purchase which I purchased
to be in Deadpool six let's read some of
those polls
go do you think Deadpool will be a
variant or resounding 59 at 59 59 of you
say no there will be variant Deadpools I
don't see it I think we gotta have the
squirrel one right this is the
Multiverse Saga and it's gonna they're
gonna be doing variants and like
multiples in all these movies I think
the end Secret Wars will leave us with
one timeline I think they're gonna wipe
out a lot of stuff and again secret
words will be taking place after this
yeah yeah way after this and this could
be like okay one of my multiverses I
just got them away not that way after
this Secret Wars will be ending the
phase that this film is kind of
beginning right so it's like it's not
that far after it
um yeah uh and somebody oh ammo and the
chat said Zach has been a great as uh
Cyril Carn and Andor to all this
big-nosed pale white guys look the same
to you ammo also that that actor's much
more handsome than me hey
microaggression am I right Zach has had
all of his uh new rock star shirts
personally tailored though yeah um
[Laughter]
I liked that guy he's creative and
innovated with his with his words
appreciate that that's a hobby and a
passion yeah yeah is it the wrong Hobby
and passion probably maybe but the
empire was right that's all I know we
love Zach from his cartoon Watcher to
his burning crotch
dude do we think now that we know that
Wolverine's gonna be in this yeah is
this like our fur our first X-Men I'm
not gonna say first communion because
we've had mutants we're gonna have more
mutants with like name or but is this
like our first X-Men officially in the
MCU like will they introduce do you
think in between now and Deadpool 3
they'll find a way to put in like it's
gonna be a storm in we're kind of
forever is there going to be a a jubilee
Trilogy that comes out
in the Marvels which a lot of people are
wondering about yeah okay I still want
them to introduce Rogue into Disney by
having her pair up with Elsa because
they need to go glove shopping because
so they both have really they got such a
problem they got touch problems and they
need gloves and they need to go together
because girl gay girl glove shopping is
just what I want to see so that's my
head Cannon for how rogue's gonna enter
I don't present in their super chat but
someone did send in one I apologies
we'll find you in a second uh asking
which Disney princess dress will
Deadpool wear first oh nice I mean I
think I think you've got two options at
the time I'm going to jump in on this
hell yeah do it Bell is your most iconic
one I think it turns out the most
Cinderella is Iconic it's a little old
school for the Zoomers out there they
don't know it as well I'll also throw
out Rapunzel's dress very popular
doesn't it look so similar to a lot of
the other dresses
Elsa's blue dress because Frozen is like
the most recent popular princess dress
to get on I think I'm gonna go
Tinkerbell you guys oh
take it like that I will also throw out
Aurora's dress as a in between the pink
and blue switching back and forth it
could be a lot of fun for him or perhaps
the dress Diana wore on her wedding day
princess oh my god oh that was from
letter rest those are Mikey cheers Mikey
cheers so much uh also Austin long said
in a Super Chat he was he was saying
nice things about us They said Jubilee
is still mid which uh I know you don't
believe that Austin along which is which
makes me even more upset that you don't
even believe that don't let MTV say that
dude you guys are lucky mt's not here he
would start crying I'm a rational man
who loves Jubilee but Mt empty would
find you empty would find you hunt you
down and and just SOB in your door I
also want to say you would send your
fingers
the nature of this announcement even
even name checks sorry we didn't make it
a d23 right is Kevin feige letting
anybody else announce their own movie oh
right this is I mean Ryan Reynolds has
always been a passion project right he
financed that Sizzle
he's an executive producer yes yeah he's
much more involved than any other actor
in the MCU right like maybe with the
exception of Robert Downey Jr uh and and
like uh he financed that original
scissors real they got the first movie
Green lit he's been super for Hands-On
he's kind of worked his way through a
couple directors right
will uh something Miller right he was
the director of the first film clashed
with him on the second films they
brought in uh he portrayed Tim Miller
yeah he portrayed an awful awful version
of Deadpool that's how much he loved
Wade Wilson he was like I will do this
what he knew was a terrible version of
Deadpool the next minute
oh what oh that version yeah yeah he's
even said he's going to bring back that
version of I just real quick
um off-screen sometimes on screen
producer John who does all the technical
stuff for the show he's a brilliant
director has not yet figured out a
better way to communicate with us than
screaming from the other room
not picked up on microphones we said put
on a god mic back here but he said why
do I need a Cod mic when I'm God don't
need a microphone
I was an atheist until I realized John
was God
awesome
I thought you're gonna say may he shout
from his his producer
to his Screech from his director to his
record okay um I was gonna go director
but yeah oh
his Bible spouter to his weeper and
powder you know what I'm saying I I do
just want to when we'll close this
Deadpool discussion again we'll we'll
get hopefully we get a lot more news
they haven't even started production on
this film yet it's almost exactly two
years out but like yeah the fact that he
gets to announce this they've done Comic
Con was not that long ago d23 there's a
lot of opportunities for Disney to
announce this they let him do this on
his own so clearly you know he is
shaping this as much as like the Marvel
infrastructure so maybe that is a little
evidence that it might exist a little
bit on an ironic placement he had his
own gin in the ad itself I think that
Kevin will let Miss Marvel probably
announce something come on vilani
because she's so into it too like she's
just yeah like let her make a little
yeah yeah like a sloth baby production
announces whatever it was Marvel season
two or whatever
I think that could happen if he gets
someone real big for uh Fantastic Four I
could see them like letting uh that
person like make the announcement like I
will be this character and the movie is
coming out now on their own channel not
through official Marvel channels or
anything like that I don't know maybe
not I wouldn't doubt if this is the only
time we ever see it might be it might be
uh but
um Tommy yep uh do you have an idea
maybe from how your body parts from your
shouter to your spouter from my big
shout to my wine spout oh uh yeah
it's time for mandatory
the segment that has warmed everyone's
heart so we gotta show a visual chart
hit that graphic again
oh Tommy's slowly getting warm
segmented honors the monarchy so we can
make that sweet Super Champ money we
play it again
God save the segment okay now
last week I had you all pick a player
for your and or fantasy team you were
not here I wasn't here
you were Jessica today we're gonna keep
Jessica in the game even though she is
not with us today she will be back next
week so Whitney pressures on you and I
don't know if you know yeah I was gonna
say I don't know Jessica
dude Jessica's really competitive I
can't do this before we do the draft I'm
gonna give you guys an update on your
scores and how those scores were done
now Jessica picked Bix our junkyard
feisty potentially former lover of Andor
and I gave Jessica eight points so
here's where she scored her points she
used a kiss to manipulate a person maybe
more than a kiss well what we saw was a
kiss then she also used secret language
to sneak in or to get access to a place
where she she didn't get into like a
galactic phone booth and Page someone
right like she went into the parts store
and was like I need to go into the
seventh rack and he's like damn are the
yellow ones and then she went in and
paged uh Lutheran so anyway Jessica gets
eight points for that Zach you also get
eight points and let me tell you why oh
you picked Marva one of my favorite
characters I don't know where the dye is
right here oh okay oh Brandon's got it
great I don't know what you're like my
grandpa I thought that was like one of
those little bears you buy at gas
stations that people use it turn them
into crack pipes
okay here's why I gave you uh let's see
you got uh uh 10 points for a uh cheeky
relationship with a Droid okay uh you
got 10 points for that and then I
subtracted two points for a very like
boilerplate Lane like this is the sound
of an Empire beginning to predictive I
love that scene
before a fire will rise wow this she's
just like Bane like the wheel anyway so
you got eight points as well Brandon
you have Android here's the thing it's
tough to have to score and or he's the
protagonist but this is fantasy football
when you draft and you pick a stud you
pick a great running back you pick a
great player they score a lot of points
and I give Andor 15 points
okay I gave him five points for
cold-blooded murder oh oh yeah I gave
him five points for lying slash
deception and I gave him five points for
skipping the easy way out of a situation
and doing the most convoluted difficult
thing possible and still surviving and
getting away on a Speeder bike so that
gives you 15 points now my judging is
fair no and it is fine
baby Marva gets no points for drugging a
child yeah come on that's pretty good
yeah you know what I'm gonna give Marva
three points I'm putting up to 11. yeah
I'm a merciful commissioner and I'm fair
you plead your case oh up the stakes
okay now I also gave myself and
therefore the chat I'm representing the
chat we had my boy serial current US 10
points and I was very fearful okay five
points for Grand ambition for like over
ambition and five points for cowardice
this classic bad guy cowardice
12.
14 men 14 men that's like me describing
college that one night when I took on
the whole party how many people were
there at least 12 perhaps 14. anyway
very popular with a lacrosse team uh so
this week we got a draft real quick time
when you say took on yeah the lacrosse I
fought him make for me Tommy make for me
I fought him with my mouth hands and
butt uh
laughs
come on
I said I fought it
okay come on come out
Jack you just spit all over the desert
scroll up Scroll up God damn it I gotta
let everyone in my family watching
forget about it okay so this week this
week we've got four characters
we got four characters to uh oh my four
characters to uh pick from now we're
scrolling back from backwards so I'll
let you guys roll and then I'll let you
know who you're picking okay okay okay
okay okay so everybody I got a six we
got a six-sided die all right here we go
we got three okay on behalf of Jessica
for the consolation
okay wait so you're wrong oh between us
oh I see one not me not one
all right so it's gonna go Zach Brandon
Whitney all right Zach you have a choice
of picking between Lutheran
or Cyril card okay I'm gonna explain my
logic here so we have yet to see my
mouth that's true so in theory B the
first episode we see that character
might be a big entrance right I might do
a lot of stuff but I gotta go the
titular character in in Lutheran had a
great last episode and you know like now
that he's kind of driving the ship
recruiting and all this kind of stuff my
favorite thing was his walking stick
looks like the lightsabers you buy at
the point yes yeah because it's kind of
white and it has like a lightsaber I was
like does he have like a weapon recently
he's got a SoCal locals yeah has he been
to the black spiers
sons traveler uh still in Skarsgard
thank you that's great dude he's so good
in that role that voice uh but I gotta
go and door
because I think we're gonna keep
bouncing back and forth between
President and flashback and so a lot of
scoring opportunities all right Brandon
you got between pick between Luther and
Mothman
Whitney you've got zero card or Lupine
I'm gonna go with loosen this is the
goddamn tree
and then I guess once again for week
number two the chat and I are stuck with
serial Khan well luckily I'm the one who
comes up with the points
they have a big old week we've done
predictions for series a lot of
different ways but this time it's just
totally subjective yeah Tommy bechtels
are in my Dark Twisted Fantasy like
Kanye
it's a great John Legend uh John Lennon
uh solo track God I wish somebody would
bring John Lennon back to life and kill
John Lincoln no all right how about John
Legend John Legend should cover John
Lennon why not real quick before we go
out let's uh we've had a lot of great
super chats uh vasilis uh cafellinos you
have a great name vasilis I hope I'm
pronouncing it well a Deadpool suit kind
of looks like the Venom symbiotic suit
from the comics uh you know when I left
a little piece behind and no way home it
was a really weird yeah
um uh Jordan of the MCU uh DCU said uh
from your talker to your knocker yeah
uh Ben Enoch asking and he had a couple
super chats in there we appreciate you
Ben how to apply for a job asking for a
friend
um we're not currently hiring I don't
think we have any openings until we fire
Tommy but uh well send in a few super
chats asking for it okay there will be
actually demand to give me a job there
will be an opening immediately after
this show for co-hosts
[Laughter]
this job without a fight and I think we
all know what that entails now okay
let's go this way you're fighting the
Holy Trinity if you take me
you're fighting the father Son and Holy
Ghost and then uh she's saying give me a
job you know what um again not currently
hiring if you're La local though you
know we're a growing company and um if
if if you're a good candidate uh you
never know
um stay stay tuned we'll announce it
publicly if we ever uh need to hire more
folks
um uh Miss MLS bead saying is it
possible that we will get a close-up of
the world we are incursioning on I guess
that if maybe if in Deadpool right if
there was some kind of incursion or
certainly a Fantastic Four that would be
that would be a fun premise right if
whatever World Deadpool is from like
that's the one it is like I gotta get
out I gotta get my buddy Wolverine I
gotta get grab Wolverine and get the
[ __ ]
I'm really proud of you you guys I
wasn't I was I'm pretty sure that I
wasn't allowed back on the break room
for that long because I'm just joking
so now I'm on my best behavior you know
they have allowed me to be here every
day
uh Ben Enoch had another good one what
MCU hero will Deadpool interact with
first so not that he has not yet
currently interacted with so none of
that he's already interacted with the
X-Men and the X-Force I mean exchange
kind of makes sense so I was gonna say
it wrong I put my money oh yeah where's
the glue as long as one gets first
passed on a roll in Deadpool three
that's that's for him he could have a
threesome with the marina background and
uh Madison oh could happen
hello
fantastic
we're fantastic
anytime yeah thank you
um should we cover some of these polls
real quick yeah
[Applause]
all right let's see we got when do you
think we're gonna see these are all the
way back from our headlines guys so
reach deep back in you know the recesses
of your minds when do you think we'll
see Scarlet Witch again phase six 44 I
think that makes sense why Rush your
back we just went through all that
trouble to make her disappear into a Red
Mist you know uh it's like when a
wrestler goes away you gotta you gotta
let people breathe then you bring them
back or her back I think she'll be in
the Agatha Harkness show yeah probably
at the end oh is this scrapped
post-credits scene we're talking about
the uh Namor from Black Panther one
better than the one we got in Black
Panther one a very a nail binder if you
will yes 52 knows 47 which is ridiculous
how did it get wet feet
we all agree he needs slippers
how else you're gonna tease me more
that's right show him yeah
because he's in the middle of Africa
there's no one near the ocean there's
water who's in a lake well how are the
how are they going to get there how are
these two people gonna fight these two
groups why is that the problem is not
they can't get there the problem is his
feet are dry as Hell by the time yeah by
the time he gets there his feet would be
dry you know sometimes I take socks off
I'm a fear wet you know what right
now
let me tell you it wasn't that hard how
many times we have to go away how wet
was that money by the way so how many
times but not with water how many times
do we have to get up to pee during two
hours and 40 minutes of black panther
wakanda forever never I can hold it says
73
that's so many lies I got a walnut for a
prostate
you're pee in your pants every every
movie Once 17 those people are slightly
more truthful twice five percent the
only honest people in this chat and more
than twice for my ex-girlfriend who will
get up 15 times I mean more than twice
you gotta just don't buy a soda yeah you
know what I mean you can't buy it if
you're gonna use it I don't feel like a
two-way street on your cup right that's
right whether it's a mandatory fun mug
or the now collectible morbid time mugs
uh what I what I take I also make okay
Jesus Christ honestly I don't pee during
the movies but I do hit the bathroom a
couple of times oh
laser focus laser focus I got a lot to
say about this movie I'm taking notes
for work
there's so many DFX are discredited
um we should get to a bar after this
right right away right away Uh Hungry
Brandon not at all does anyone have any
cigarettes uh I hope you guys have
enjoyed the last ever episode of the
break room
um John has already moved to cancel the
show uh I play Ryan Reynolds this stop
streaming 15 minutes ago
script very cohesive discussion points
and they all got thrown out because of
Brian Wright and how appropriate that on
the day of the big Deadpool news we get
a little wild a little dirty uh totally
appropriate
um oh uh final last little Super Chat
the this six inch Galaxy is that that
person's yeah yeah he's Deadpool 3 going
to be the going to be Hugh Mungus
so uh we'll be back tomorrow watch Andor
tonight watch Wikileaks tomorrow with
Tommy and Eric
um and then tomorrow we got Andor
tonight and then we got She-Hulk
tomorrow night and then we got uh rings
of power the night after that it's a
great time check out talking dragons
yeah yeah check out talking drags if you
don't watch my Rick and Morty video I'll
kill myself no Jesus
hit like on this video right now I love
free girl yesterday was reminded folks
to do that if you're still watching hit
like subscribe uh go go buy a mandatory
fun mug from new rockstarsmerch.com and
we've got a new merch on the pipeline
yeah there's some fun things
because that was very awkward We're not
gonna fight anymore we didn't want to
fight in the first place but we are
making competing
also when you fight when you fight with
Tommy yeah
don't bring a knife to a mouth
you can't oh my God later skaters
goodbye